all right heading into the new year a
lot of people make the resolution to go
plant-based to kick off the new year
well here to tell us more and give us a
lesson in veganuary is robbie cunningham
of gorilla pizza the sponsors of this
segment welcome and you have brought
some goodies with you a lot of people
think okay if i'm not eating meat i'm
not getting flavor i'm not getting i'm
not getting the protein but that is not
the case this looks amazing what are you
gonna make for us today so um we are
going to make a what we call the glitter
gulch
it is a vegan pizza with no cheese
we're going to put some sauce on there
we're going to put a little bit of fresh
make falafel we're going to put some
tabouleh salad and then we're going to
have some wonderful tomb as like a
drizzle afterwards okay and then the
secret ingredient what is that that wait
can we
focus on this what is this it looks like
gold dust or something yeah so we got
some gold glitter
that we spray on
it's interesting to hear like cheese
cheeseless pizza
yeah so it in a you know it's very
subtle but there's there's so much
flavor and texture from the falafel from
the tabouli salad it doesn't really need
the cheese
but we're going to put some house made
pizza sauce on here
what is tabouleh salad for those that
don't know tabouli salad is
going to have parsley cilantro
a little bit of mint
bulgur which is like a cracked wheat
almost like a uh like a grits okay kind
of
that's in there also with lemon juice
garlic and tomato oh man this is really
fragrant i'm going to throw this in the
oven okay so we're putting the the sauce
the
dough and then what did you put on the
falafel and then just the falafel okay
and then we'll take this beautiful
cooked pizza this is out of the oven
okay
so now do we go ahead and uh get our
spatula
we got all the necessities here at las
vegas now
we'll just get that right here it's
clean it's clean it works
i cleaned it myself
now you're putting the salad on top yeah
so we're going to put the tabouli
right here in the middle
and if people want to go to gorilla
pizza where are you guys located we are
located inside the hard hat lounge
um
we are over on industrial road
and wyoming oh wow and we'll be doing
this pizza for the whole month of
january
um we are doing it part of vegan dining
month which has been going on for about
five years
uh put on by diana edelman and uh she
started as kind of like a response for
restaurant week since they didn't have a
whole lot of vegan options that's
perfect it allows a lot of restaurants
to do a great vegan option so a lot of
the las vegas
culinary scene
restaurant scene is doing a bunch of
great
vegan pizzas right now vegan food
seconds left so i want to make sure we
tell everyone what is this that you're
putting on uh we're putting the tumon
right here okay and then
a lot of fresh garlic and then
oh there you go check out that sparkle
beauty oh my gosh this looks fantastic
gorilla pizza thank you so much we're
gonna enjoy this and las vegas now we'll
be right back